[Music]
well the tech company Airbnb which is
run by very rich people who are
definitely your moral betters use the
State of the Union address as an
opportunity to denounce the Trump
administration and it's immigration
policy the company debuted a new ad just
before the speech that ridicules the
president's recent comments about poor
and dangerous country service part of it
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll see you in port-au-prince short
time ago we spoke to Airbnb 'he's head
of policy was also former aide to
President Bill Clinton Chris Lehane
Chris thanks for coming up thanks for
having me talk about how are you doing
I'm doing great so I'm obviously very
familiar with your work for many years
in the political sphere now you're
working for a big commercial company and
I'm a little confused by the message of
the ad the message appears to be the
president is immoral but were virtuous
therefore spend money with us is that
the what is that the message I don't
think I don't think that car did you
know where is you just use if you're
anywhere in the ad in fact no they don't
you actually look at if you look through
the trajectory of things we actually ran
our first ad along these lines on Fox
last year during this we appreciate that
I'm in an ad we ran it yeah I'm sure you
do it I'm sure the company did but the
at was really focused on the same
subject matter that this ad is focused
on which is this concept of we accept
right we're a people to people based
platform we have over 250 million users
their global 191 countries and we do
believe our mission is to allow anyone
to belong anywhere and so last year on
the Superbowl we read an ad about we
accept which really embraced the idea of
inclusion and diversity it was in
response to the travel ban that took
place and really over the course of the
year we have continued to step out on
issues there were we do win consistent
with our core mission of allowing anyone
to belong anywhere so this ad that we
reinstall your stoles the virtues of
some wonderful people because you're
virtuous and you're not in this to get
rich I doubt you take a salary from
Airbnb just a moral satisfaction being
on the right side
how much do our hosts Tucker make on
each transaction Vic that's pretty clear
I'm not tacking air being but I'm
attacking your mischaracterization of it
no the point is clear that we are a
virtuous company we accept in contrast
to the bigoted president who seeks to
exclude we're good he's evil spend money
with us and I'm merely asking you a kind
of commercial question which is is that
a good play for you to say we're the
virtuous company we're not really in
this for the money
we're in it because we're just really
good people I mean that's a reason is
obviously the reason you're not writing
add scripts because that's not what the
ad said right I think it's really
important to actually look at what the
ad said Oh what did the ad say the ad
said that there's a beautiful people and
beautiful places and ultimately what you
come back to is whether is our mission
our mission is to allow anyone to belong
anywhere we take people offline online
and connect them offline from different
backgrounds that's great but I'm just
saying hold on you in this ad say you
know come to Haiti so that wouldn't have
you I don't ask questions serious
question have you walked without
protection through downtown
port-au-prince recently and if so how'd
it go I walked recently and actually
spent a couple nights in Khayelitsha
which is a township in South Africa
outside of Cape Town so yeah I'm into
those places yes I have yes I have and
there's why have you spent the night in
some of these Christian care so you
can't filibuster you have to just let's
be polite and answer simple questions
your ad I'm glad you went to Cape Town
which is your richest place on the
continent of Africa
I'm asking about port-au-prince Haiti
about which I know a fair amount i
suspect you don't and I'm telling you
it's a very dangerous place is it
immoral unvirtuous bigoted
to acknowledge that not everywhere in
the world is the same and some places
are really dangerous in some places
aren't is that okay or is that a species
of bigotry and unacceptance well I think
what is wrong is the cast aspersions on
an entire people in an entire country
well I think the best way and all the
data supports this all the data supports
this the best way to break down
differences is to have people from
different backgrounds spend time with
one another not to criticize them not to
condemn them not to impugn them but
actually for people to offline spend
some no time will you believe will you
pledge to personally with your family go
on vacation in Haiti not at some rich
people resort but in downtown
port-au-prince the capital city and
spend a week just in order to kind of
get that Ross cultural pollenization
that's so very important why don't you
do that and why don't you come back and
tell me what kind of time you had so
Tucker first of all if you want to talk
about my family I'm happy to my guess is
my family may have a little bit more
diversity than your family cultural
diversity of talking about
port-au-prince Haiti is a network of
family values I'm not asking your family
would you like me to answer the question
so the answer is we're actually planning
a trip to Africa where we're actually
going to be going through some of these
townships that I've talked about you'll
be surprised at Haiti's nobody in Africa
so I hope you I hope that occurs well on
your trip at some point in the Caribbean
your question is getting at weather I
and my family are willing to travel to
places in the world that people
typically do not travel to and I am
happy to take my family and we've taken
out my family to these types of places
in the pair's because I actually do
believe in what our platform is trying
to do you know just which is wait to
take teammate from one background or
connect them from different backgrounds
right right now I get that that you mean
okay I do it did you get ordained you
got house job these questions last year
when I ran the when we ran the ad on Fox
during the Superbowl because last year I
didn't why your time important Chris why
didn't you ask these last year oh I
don't know probably some sinister reason
actually I didn't see the spot is the
truth but I appreciate your coming on
tonight Thanks